Speaker 1: All right, so this is sort of like a
kind of keep track segment as we hear more and
more about the people that knew and were involved
in exactly what the plan was between the November
2020 election and January six, the day of the
Trump riots to try to steal the election from the
guy who really won it, Joe Biden, and hand it over
to Donald Trump in some kind of way. You can use
the term coup or insurrection or whatever term you
want to use. Every time we hear from another one
of these Trump insiders, we realize it was much
more premeditated than initially was believed,
although there is no question that I mean, listen,
if for the six months leading up to the election,
they're basically telling us, we're going to say
the votes were invalid, we're going to say that
it was all fraudulent, et cetera. If they tell
you that for six months, you should believe that
that's what they're going to do and that's exactly
what they did. But there is an incredible new
article in The Daily Beast that now outlines Trump
economic adviser Peter Navarro in an interview
straight up telling them what the plan was and
how he coordinated with Stephen Bannon. Read the
entire article. We're going to take a look at
it. The article in The Daily Beast is called.
Trump adviser Peter Navarro lays out how he and
Bannon planned to overturn Biden's electoral win,
and it's exactly what we believed. And even
worse, a former Trump White House official
says he and right wing provocateur Steve Bannon
were behind the last ditch effort to try to stop
the certification of the 2020 election results
and keep Trump in power. They even had a name
for the plan called the Green Bay sweep. In
his recently published memoir, Peter Navarro,
Trump's trade adviser, explains how he stayed
in contact with Bannon as they put the Green Bay
sweep in motion with help from members loyal of
Congress members of Congress loyal to the cause.
But in an interview last week with The Daily
Beast, Navarro shed additional light on his role
and their coordination with politicians like
Paul Gosar and Senator Ted Cruz quote. We spent
a lot of time lining up over 100 congressmen,
including some senators. It started out perfectly
at one p.m. GOES-R and Cruz did exactly what was
expected of them. It was a perfect plan. It all
predicated on peace and calm on Capitol Hill. We
didn't even need protesters because we had over
100 congressmen committed to it. That commitment
appeared as Congress was certifying the votes.
You'll remember Senator Cruz signed off
on GOES-R official objection to counting
Arizona's electoral ballots. Remember that there
is this. This was an issue back in 2000 with
Al Gore and George W. Bush in that election as
well. The way that these objections work are that
a member of the House rises in objection. And
then they are asked, Do you have the support of
a member of the Senate? And typically the answer
is no in this case. Cruz was the Senate guy
who was going to sign on to that. Staffers for
Cruz and Goes ARE did not respond for requests for
comment. There's no public indication whether the
Jan. six committee wants testimony or documents
from Cruz or Gosar, but they've only started
to seek evidence. The last minute maneuvering
never had any chance of actually decertifying
the election results on its own. A point that
Navarro quickly acknowledges. But their hope was
to run the clock as long as possible to increase
pressure on Mike Pence to send electoral votes
back to six contested states. Now, understand that
every time we learn more about the plan,
it's the same story that we are hearing
now that we have the memo that was written by
Eastman, the lawyer Eastman, and presented to
the White House about how this all could work.
One of the big three points that was made was
make it so that we put pressure on Pence
to either reject the electoral ballots
from certain states or, even better, even more
directly. Even more aggressively, you could say,
seat an alternative slate of electors what
they wanted Pence to do. And, of course, legal.
Most legal experts say Pence couldn't actually do
this. What they wanted to do was say, you know,
in these different states, Arizona, I don't
remember the full list, but it was like Arizona,
Georgia, Michigan, Wisconsin, maybe Nevada.
They wanted Pence to say, Well, you know what?
We can't trust these numbers. And so instead
of allowing the Democratic electors to vote
because the Democratic candidate won
the state, I am going to bring in an
alternative slate of Republican electors who
will cast their votes for Trump instead of
Joe Biden. That was one idea. Pence couldn't
really do that. The other idea that they floated
was, OK, you don't bring an alternative slate of
electors, but you say because it's unclear who
really won some of these states. We're just going
to take those electors off the table. And what
that does is it makes it so that the threshold
for winning instead of being 270 electoral votes
is some lower number, ideally a lower number,
which Donald Trump did have that that was the
other idea. So when we look at this article, we
realize this is part of that same plan. It was all
coordinated the legal opinions that Trump had in
front of them and the idea of putting Pence in a
position to take action. It's the same thing that
Peter Navarro and Steve Bannon were working on.
What else do we have here? The Green Bay sweep
was very well thought out. It was designed to
get us 24 hours of televised hearings, but we
thought that we could bypass the corporate media
by getting this stuff televised. Navarro's part
in the ploy was to provide the raw materials
that came in the form of a three part White
House report called The Immaculate Deception and
the Art of the Steal. My role was to provide the
receipts for the 100 congressmen or so who would
make their cases, who could rely in part on the
body of evidence I'd collected to lay the legal
predicate for the actions to be taken. And the
article points out. Ultimately, states have not
found any evidence of electoral fraud above the
norm, which is exceedingly small. I think it was
was it was it Wisconsin or Georgia that found, I
think four dead people voted, and I think three of
them just died after submitting their votes? You
know, we're talking about numbers like that. The
next phase was up to Bannon, Navarro describes in
his memoir. Steve Bannon's role was to figure out
how to use this information, what he called the
receipts to overturn the election result. That's
how Steve came up with the Green Bay sweep idea.
The political and legal beauty of the strategy
was this by law, both the House and Senate must
spend up to two hours of debate per state on
each challenge for the six battleground states,
that would be as much as 24 hours of televised
hearings, so that was the idea. Now, according
to this plan, you can argue that the violence
hurt the plan. And what I mean by that is part
of the reason why the hearings didn't happen.
And you didn't have 24 hours, because remember the
day that a hundred thousand of you assembled it
was actually about 1.3 million different people.
Joined my coverage of the Jan. six Trump riots,
my expectation on that day was that we were going
to see objection after objection after objection,
each with two hours of debate, and that I would
step away from the coverage and we would just
stream the coverage. And it was going to go into
the night 24 hours, maybe even 30 hours. We were
thinking the reason it didn't happen is because
of the riots. And so one could make the case that
this plan, although it wasn't going to work to
steal the election, that this plan was derailed
by the fact that the riots took place. Now that
would lead us to the question, well, then why
would Trump incite the riots? Trump hasn't all
of the above approach. Trump doesn't have the
sophistication and the ability for abstract
thinking to realize, well, this plan and the
riot inciting could end up conflicting and causing
a problem. Trump's ideas just do do everything, do
this and try to convince Pence and then, you know,
cause chaos. And ultimately, because the debate
stopped because of the risk, the physical risk
of violence to members of the House and Senate.
This ended up not happening now. This ultimately
wasn't going to work, but it might have actually
gotten them those 24 hours of TV coverage that
they wanted. So again, it's all out in the
open. They're admitting that this was the plan to
steal an election that they did not actually win.